Argelia ha dicho adiós a sus días bajo el
gobierno del presidente Abdelaziz Bouteflika.
Han sido casi 20 los años que este dirigente
ha mandado sobre Argelia.
Amigos, sus últimos tiempos han sido tan
extravagantes que habría que hacer un crossover
entre la ficción fantástico y los mitos
históricos para encontrar algo igual.
Por un lado, estamos hablando de un Bouteflika
inválido e incapaz de comunicarse que simbólicamente
recuerda al decrépito rey Theoden del Señor
de los Anillos, un gobernante en manos de
sus consejeros.
[Antes, claro, del acelerado tratamiento antiedad
que le realiza Gandalf.]
Por otro lado hemos estado a punto de ver
algo así como una especie de versión argelina
de El Cid Campeador: un Bouteflika absolutamente
incapacitado al que sus acólitos esperaban
poder montarlo sobre la silla de rueda camino
del quinto mandato presidencial.
[Un momento, ¿No sabéis quien es el cid
campeador?
No, no, no. No me refiero a este ...aunque
a veces lo parezca. Si no al personaje legendario
de la historia de España que Charlton Heston
interpretó en 1961. en la película
el Cid. Os dejo en la descripción un link
para que le podáis conocer]
El caso es que… esto ya era demasiado y
los acontecimientos se precipitaron.
No habrá quinto mandato de Bouteflika
Pero, amigos, siendo honestos eso es lo de
menos. Pensar que en Argelia hay democracia
es cómo pensar que… Maduro ganó limpiamente
sus últimas elecciones.
En Argelia hay una democracia nominal pero
no una democracia efectiva. Lo que sí hay
son un montón de interrogantes sobre la mesa.
¿Qué ha supuesto Bouteflika para la Historia
de Argelia? ¿Qué va a pasar ahora que Bouteflika
lo deja? ¿Estamos a punto de presenciar un
nuevo capítulo de la Primavera árabe?
En VisualPolitik hoy vamos a dar respuesta
a todas estas preguntas, pero antes, vamos
a ver un poco, un poco de historia.
Atentos.
(EL ORIGEN)
Amigos, no hace falta más que echar un vistazo
a la historia reciente de Argelia para comprender
el enorme peso que siempre ha tenido el Ejército
en este país.
En los últimos 60 años Argelia ha vivido
una Guerra de Liberación contra los franceses,
una dictadura militar durante más de dos
décadas y una Guerra Civil de 10 años.
[Dicho de otra forma. Durante los últimos
60 años, de una forma u otra, el ejército
argelino ha sido el protagonista principal
de la actualidad y la política nacional]
(De no haber sido por su repentina dimisión,
el 27 de abril de 2019 se hubieran cumplido
20 años desde que el ejército entregó el
poder a Bouteflika. En aquel momento Bouteflika
estaba considerado como el Presidente de consenso
para Argelia.
Dos décadas después no son pocos quienes
ven este periodo como el de mayor estabilidad
para Argelia, que con los años se han convertido
en uno de los países más seguros del mundo
árabe.)
Sin embargo, para muchos analistas más que
de estabilidad hay que hablar de estancamiento.
Pero, un momento, antes de continuar creo
que tenemos que responder a una pregunta fundamental:
¿Quién diantres es Abdelaziz Bouteflika?
Amigos, nuestro protagonista nació hace 82
años en Oujda, una ciudad de Marruecos fronteriza
con Argelia. Sus padres eran argelinos y con
19 años se fue a pelear contra los franceses
con el Ejército de Liberación Nacional.
Durante la guerra, su carrera fue meteórica
y entró a formar parte del círculo de confianza
del coronel Houari Boumédiène, jefe del
Estado mayor…
De esta forma, una vez conseguida la independencia
del país, en 1962, Bouteflika con tan solo
25 años ya era ministro. Y al poco tiempo,
cuando el propio Boumédiène, entonces ministro
de Defensa, dio un golpe de Estado - dando
paso a una dictadura militar - nuestro protagonista
en este vídeo jugó un papel clave Fijaos,.
(Hoauri Boumédiene fue el presidente de Argelia
hasta su muerte en 1978. Junto a él, Bouteflika
fue el ministro argelino de Exteriores durante
todo el periodo de la dictadura.
Pero claro, tras el fallecimiento de Boumédiene
pasó lo que le suele pasar a las personas
que colaboran o formar parte de una dictadura:
Bouteflika cayó en desgracia.
Fue acusado y condenado por corrupción, su
imagen pública quedó por los suelos y tuvo
que trasladarse a vivir a Europa.)
Eso sí, no tardaría mucho en regresar a
una Argelia con muchos problemas.
En aquel momento, hablamos de finales de los
años 80 y principios de los 90, la República
argelina intentaba dejar atrás el régimen
de partido único y convertirse de una vez
por todas en una auténtica democracia.
Precisamente en este contexto, en 1991 se
celebraron las primeras elecciones parlamentarias
libres.
En la primera vuelta, la victoria del Partido
Islamista fue rotunda. La segunda vuelta ya
no tuvo lugar. El Ejército anuló las votaciones
antes de que los islamistas lograran la mayoría
suficiente para cambiar la Constitución y
convertir Argelia en un nuevo Irán.
Argelia comenzó entonces una guerra civil
contra el islamismo. ¿El saldo? 200.000 muertos
en una década.
(LE POUVOIR)
Fue entonces, tras la guerra civil, cuando
llegó la hora de Bouteflika.
(En 1999 de forma inesperada el presidente
militar Liamine Zéroual renunció y convocó
elecciones presidenciales.
Entonces el Ejército que no quería ni por
asomo unas elecciones libres vio en Bouteflika
a la persona indicada para llevar a Argelia
a la reconciliación nacional.)
Y, efectivamente, el Gobierno de Bouteflika
supo acabar con la Guerra Civil. Supo actuar
con mano izquierda en los peores momentos.
Y, no solo eso, Bouteflika abrió la economía
del país a la inversión extranjera. Lo que
posibilitó que los ingresos del gas y el
petróleo sostuvieran las políticas sociales
del Gobierno.
Desde entonces, amigos, Argelia se ha convertido
en una especie país rentista.
Gran parte de la población se acostumbró
muy pronto a los subsidio y a que los productos
básicos estuvieran fuertemente subvencionados.
Todo ello le permitió a Bouteflika mantener
el apoyo popular sin tener que dar un sólo
paso hacia la democratización efectiva del
país.
(Desde la llegada al poder de Bouteflika el
poder se ha concentrado cada vez más en el
Palacio Presidencial, hasta tal punto que
las instituciones políticas en la práctica
dejaron de tener valor. Bouteflika era el
poder.
La concentración de poder era tan grande
que cuando en 2013 el líder sufrió un derrame
cerebral, nadie supo ver una alternativa.
No había un plan alternativo. El plan A,
el B, el C, el D… todos pasaban por Bouteflika
como líder político del país.)
El derrame dio lugar a una de los escenarios
más surrealistas que han visto en la política
de un país.
Bouteflika quedó postrado en una silla de
ruedas, sin prácticamente capacidad de hablar
y completamente dependiente. Evidentemente
en esas condiciones el presidente estaba absolutamente
incapacitado para gobernar el país.
Sin embargo, cuando en 2014 se celebraron
elecciones presidenciales, nadie pensó en
sustituto.
Durante la campaña electoral, el presidente
no pudo ni siquiera dirigirse a la población
pero a pesar de ello obtuvo una nueva victoria.
[No os extrañeis, la democracia argelina
es así, los resultados se determinan antes
de las propias votaciones]
Ahora bien, claro, la pregunta que muchos
os estaréis haciendo es… pero bueno, vamos
a ver Alberto. Si el viejo líder es incapaz
de dar una orden , ¿Quién diantres manda
en Argelia?
Amigos ahí es, precisamente, donde entra
en juego Le Pouvoir.
(Pouvoir es una palabra francesa que significa
poder. . Así que el poder, o le pouvoir como
dicen en Argelia, es una expresión para hacer
referencia a las élites que han dominado
la República Argelina desde la independencia
del país. Unas élites políticas, económicas
y militares que durante los últimos 6 años
han sido incapaces de consensuar un nuevo
presidente)
[Sí, ya os podéis hacer una idea de cómo
funciona realmente la democracia argelina.]
Ahora bien, el no lograr un candidato de consenso
no es algo que les preocupara mucho a estas
élites: al fin y al cabo ya tenían a Bouteflika
para mantener sus privilegios y su control
sobre el país.
Sin embargo amigo, en esta ocasión cometieron
un error de cálculo.
Atentos.
(EL LÍMITE)
Desde el año 2014, la caída de los precios
del petróleo y del gas natural ha supuesto
un duro golpe para la economía argelina.
Los ingresos del país disminuyeron un 50%.
Y, ojo, no hay que olvidar que más de la
mitad del Presupuesto de Argelia se financia
con las exportaciones de hidrocarburos.
Por su parte la balanza de pagos se ha desequilibrado
de tal manera que se llegaron a tomar medidas
tan extremas como esta.
(Argelia prohíbe la importación de teléfonos
móviles, muebles y alimentos para frenar
el déficit comercial. Dailystar)
Y, por supuesto, además de estas prohibiciones,
otros muchos bienes fueron gravados con aranceles
muy altos.
Y es que claro, cuando un país rentista pierde
sus rentas… pues… ¿Cómo vas a pagar
todas las compras que haces con todas esas
rentas? Pues simplemente no puedes.
Llega la época de los recortes.
(Los legisladores argelinos aprueban el presupuesto
que establece aumentos en los precios del
combustible. Reuters)
Con la caída de los precios del petróleo
y el gas, la situación de Argelia pasó a
ser crítica.
Fijaos, A pesar de que el gobierno recortó
el gasto un 10% anual, el déficit público
alcanzó la alarmante cifra del 12% del PIB.
Y, claro, al no poder financiar muchas de
las subvenciones y los subsidios que el gobierno
repartía, el coste de la vida se ha disparado
en los últimos 5 años.
[Ahora creo que ya podéis entender el enorme
descontento social que hay en Argelia.]
(Argelia: los altos precios de los alimentos
avivan el resentimiento popular)
Por si esto fuera poco, Argelia tiene una
población muy joven. La edad media del país
está por debajo de los 30 años.
Y, amigos, la combinación de mucha gente
joven y estancamiento económico puede llegar
a ser letal para este tipo de regímenes.
¿Por qué? Pues porque un país estancado
o en crisis no es capaz de crear oportunidades
para unos jóvenes que tienen la fuerza y
la vitalidad como para echarse a las calles.
Y eso es precisamente lo que ha pasado aquí.
Para los jóvenes argelinos no había más
camino que lograr el fin del régimen liderado
por “la momia - que es como popularmente
se conoce a Bouteflika.
Un régimen dictatorial y corrupto, muy corrupto,
que ha condenado al país a un estancamiento
crónico en un país que se ha tenido que
acostumbrar a noticias como esta:
(Carretera Este-Oeste: "5.000 millones de
dólares de corrupción")
De esta forma cuando el 10 de febrero el régimen
anunció la candidatura de Bouteflika para
un quinto mandato, en unas elecciones que
por supuesto estarían amañadas, eso fue
la gota que colmó el vaso.
6 días más tarde, el 16 de febrero de 2019,
comenzaron las movilizaciones contra esta
candidatura y contra este régimen.
Poco a poco las protestas se extendieron por
todo el país.
Hablamos de las mayores movilizaciones que
Argelia ha vivido desde 1999.
El éxito ha sido increíble. Apenas 6 semanas
después de iniciarse las protestas Bouteflika
se ha visto obligado a presentar su dimisión
y a dejar el poder.
(Claro que eso no significa que para Argelia
los problemas se hayan terminado.
Está por ver que las élites acepten unas
elecciones libres, sin pucherazos; que la
oposición consiga organizarse y armar una
candidatura sólida; y que realmente el resultado
de este proceso de lugar a una transición
política efectiva.
Mientras tanto la economía del país sigue
teniendo muchos, muchísimos problemas. Para
equilibrar el presupuesto, el país magrebí
necesita un precio del petróleo por encima
de 99 dólares. Actualmente se encuentra por
debajo de 70.)
Y no solo eso.
Veréis un reto que el país tiene por delante
es reducir su dependencia de los hidrocarburos.
Eso necesario, sí, pero antes que nada Argelia
tiene que liberalizar su economía y favorecer
la llegada de más inversión extranjera en
el propio sector de los hidrocarburos para
evitar que las previsiones de producción
se cumplan, fijaos.
Amigos, Argelia es uno de los mayores productores
de energía en África y un proveedor clave
de gas natural para Europa. Pero si no hay
inversión, la producción caerá.
Y Evidentemente una caída de la producción
por culpa de no haber invertido lo suficiente
agravaría seriamente los problemas económicos
del país.
[Aquí en VisualPolitik ya hemos visto que
ha ocurrido, por ejemplo, en Venezuela por
no realizar las inversiones que el sector
petrolero necesitaba. Es algo que os contamos
en este vídeo].
Ahora bien, Argelia no es Venezuela, eso es
evidente. Pero las empresas internacionales
se quejan de la enorme burocracia, la enorme
incertidumbre y la enorme corrupción que
azotan el país.
En fin amigos, cómo veis el reto al que Argelia
se enfrenta en la etapa Post-Boutflika es
enorme. ¿Qué ocurrirá a partir de ahora?
¿Logrará el país la transición política
y económica que tanto necesita o por contra
las élites de la era Bouteflika lograran
mantener su poder y control poniendo al frente
del país a otra presidente de su confianza?
Está por ver y desde luego será algo que
os contemos aqúi en VisualPolitik.
En cualquier caso esperemos que Argelia se
parezca en unos años más a Tunez que a Egipto.
Amigos si os ha resultado interesante este
vídeo darle a like y no olvidéis suscribiros
a este canal para estar al tanto de toda la
actualidad internacional.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.